yeah man that story was fascinating the
snl story i was uh and then last night
you said that you and lauren still keep
in touch a little bit oh yeah yeah
that's cool yeah i'll text you sometime
yeah we chat a little did he feel bad do
you feel like i i believe he did but you
never know yeah you know yeah you never
know you never know he could have been
the one that was like get rid of him
you know
but from his what i've heard is no
did you feel like whenever like you like
that you were going through that there
was nobody standing up for you or did
you feel like do you have any thoughts
like that sometimes you feel like that
yeah i feel like that most of my life is
the show is about that
but do you ever but did you feel like i
mean like i just wonder what some of
that was like like was there
there's yeah there's there's one thing
it's very surreal it's very surreal yeah
even your story listening to your story
about going in there yeah sitting in
there
i'm like in the story oh my god when
yeah when you're in the waiting room
like because when you go audition you're
like
i also never thought i'd get it i was
literally i was going in there like
probably not gonna get this yeah i knew
what i had done in the past
right you know
i knew my crimes i couldn't believe i
was in this [__] building
and then uh
yeah you walk in you see that stage
you're like holy [__] this is awesome
because i wasn't nervous until i saw
that
oh cause it's the real stage from yeah
you do it on the you audition on the
main stage oh wow it was crazy but uh
yeah it was cool it was cool it was
really cool but then when you get
cancelled nationally it's a very
also it's a lot smaller than you'd think
it is it's very small
that stage
wow i always thought it was huge yeah
murphy had been on there yeah um sorry
to bring that up but yeah but he was all
nervous so were you i was also on there
you were on there did you ever feel like
you were a patsy like it was a setup did
you ever think about that no i don't
think so unless it had something to do
with epstein
epstein was like that weak my story
overshadowed epstein ah
you never know oh there's a so much
power out there they could easily say
hey let's bring in a gentleman a good
gentleman and smear him
but did that ever cross your minor now
no no just from the way everybody talked
leading up to it
before the cancer like they weren't they
knew i wasn't like a conservative guy by
their standards yes i am of course but
they weren't like oh let's get this guy
because he likes trump it's like no i
literally auditioned with a joke about
trump dying right being funny
right
so
go looking back do you feel like there
was anything you could have done
different or it was just this was the
way that this was going gonna work out
no matter what uh
no i mean i definitely wouldn't have
changed
what we did my our podcast
you know yeah that's yeah that's how i
got to new york right so
what about the articles and then
suddenly your name is out there
that was crazy that's because i was
never anything right like i did like new
faces that year
and then all of a sudden it was like
you're getting i was that was what
[__] me up was like the comments
now i now i read comments i always read
i've been stuck reading comments
i can't stop reading and it doesn't like
destroy me anymore i'm starting to get
but it comes and goes like i'll be like
all right it doesn't bother me at all
and then every once in a while somebody
will get a [__] dagger on me and i'm
just like oh
uh
but i would read like articles and stuff
and i i would have like dreams i was
having like nightmares about like
articles and comments and all that [__]
it was crazy damn yeah which is so crazy
to see your name that it's like it's so
much bigger it feels so much bigger than
you you're like i'm just one
person with
and
yeah and it was all it was it was funny
sometimes like it was very funny
sometimes like because it was with my
friend matt so like
i'd be like oh [__] you remember we said
that like i totally forgot about that
and then there'd be an article that's
like judd apatow's gayer than isis and
we're like oh [__]
that's pretty funny but you know i feel
bad that shouldn't you know sucks that
he's got to see that yeah who judd
apatow yeah
true yeah i don't think he had he didn't
care obviously right
which is nice to him
because i was down he could have been
like [__] that guy yeah chimed in yeah
you ever get canceled are you gonna get
canceled do you think now we'll see how
this episode does yes
and i feel bad saying this in front of
riley over there i know
just a lot but um
anyway man uh what were we talking about
i got hired and fired by saturday live
[Laughter]
yeah it was uh it's a traumatic
experience
um but you i feel like do you feel like
there is any positives from it over time
sure have you started to notice any
positives i noticed i noticed positives
immediately did you really yeah for sure
like you go on stage and people are like
oh [__] this is
you know this is who this is this is a
guy oh wow so you went i never had z i
had zero and then to like oh this guy's
good you know or like not good but this
is a [__] freak this is who he is
this is the thing yeah this is we get to
see this freak yeah yeah but then it's
in your head when it's happening because
like you see people like at any show
people talk to each other like whisper
at the table and then like are you
[__] talking about me [__]
who are you i'm like you know
you know what i did
you [__]
yeah so you'd be up there you just
you're in your head constantly oh and
then sudden like you meet people that
are all
you know comedians in new york and i'm
like oh this [__] hates me probably or
they probably talk [__] or whatever
so it's just constant and nobody cares
no one else cares
it's just you right i wonder what most
people feel or think i guess you never
know
it's weird how
it's like yeah do people even really
care it's almost like a lot of cancel
stuff it's not even a real thing it's
just it's no one cares no one really
cared exactly what you said yeah
no one did
i never once was confronted by one
person that cared really it was always
just like well you should have been
fired you can't dude
whatever
it's kind of weird it's like this it's
like this invisible rule book this is
and we're trying like
like right now like with me trying to
sell anything or like work on anything
like a show or anything people are very
like well we like you but you know
we can't get in trouble right it's like
no one cares about nobody's like the
reason we're not picking you up is
because what you did was wrong they're
just like well we don't want to get in
trouble
it's so you know it's like a weird [__]
there's this individual because
yeah someone's like
yeah
the whole world is like
while it happened i was like oh i'm
fired for sure and then it just got
drawn out like i knew i was [__] yeah
because i think if they were mad about
that there's there's other stuff there's
a lot right like this is
you know
do you think um
do you think
that you would have fired you
no
but under the rules today's rules
yeah you have to right those are the
rules but if you want to you know what i
mean that's what i've always tried to
say like i didn't i don't
argue me getting fired right those are
today's rules if you want to talk about
like
i would have to argue like we need to
change the rules right you know yeah if
that makes sense i don't know if i'm
explaining that correctly yeah i think
so like the rules are what's
i this might not be what's wrong the
rules
there should be adjustment in the rules
yeah well it's so interesting when you
take a stand up from what's okay to be
on stage and then try to put it because
you weren't a sketch guy really are you
what no
no not really so you're in that space
suddenly
and
do you feel like you were a good fit for
the show
yeah i think i could have been yeah for
sure i think i could have done well yeah
i mean i we made sketches and i did okay
in those yeah so i think i could have
and i think lauren saw that and he was
like i think he could be good you know
yeah
uh
or i could have been decent at weekend
update something like that yeah that
would have been cool
that would have been fun
was there anybody that reached out to
you kind of that you were surprised by
that was like trying to be supportive
yeah for sure it was a lot
yeah wow every every
yeah a lot of people did norm mcdonald
was a cool one really yeah that was a
cool one i talked to him for like an
hour no on the phone yeah wow
yeah what does he say
he's another guy that's exactly who you
think he is you know yeah he's just like
yeah
i don't know i don't wanna i don't wanna
put out the private right stuff but yeah
he was he was awesome
all that stuff all that stuff is cool it
was cool stuff cool stuff happened but
it was again it was very surreal like
you'd i'd get off i'd be like holy [__]
that's like
top five for me favorite comedians of
all time just got i was just walking
around my backyard talking to him
and then i come back inside of my shitty
apartment
with my roommates with my 35 year old
male roommates
and i sit back down and turn the news on
it's like piece of [__] shane gillis was
fired what a terrible person he is
and i mean it was just very surreal so
it was kind of like
i didn't even have time to be like sad
it was just
very stressful and like kind of funny
when i was just with my friends right
you know
because they would just keep quoting and
they kept trying to get us in more
trouble by finding old quotes
and every once while they they would
miss and they wouldn't be offensive and
it would just be funny
and they would publish them like a lady
from the new york times was like the
worst he called
civil women who fought in the civil war
secretly
flat-chested [__]
and she like tweeted that
people were like this is pretty funny
stuff
[Laughter]
she was like it's not funny
yeah they knew it it made me hate the
[__] i hate journalists dude oh that's
the worst
times in new york times it's the worst
yeah it's like what are you doing knock
it off
yeah when do you think that you were
part of like
you know the eight the asian hate thing
started do you feel like getting it yeah
that was pretty bad luck do you feel
like you started that at all uh
no but i was actually yeah now you
mentioned it yes i was one of the first
i was definitely early in the asian hate
community because the after that it kind
of that's when it kind of took off i
feel like that's when
yeah
but you it it wasn't obviously
i mean that's ridiculous
no that's fine
it was kind of yeah i mean it was media
attention about a slur
right directed at asian people so yes
that definitely and
and
people are perfectly reasonable to see a
headline that says this guy said this
slur and they're perfectly reasonable to
be like [__] that guy
you know what i mean yeah because no and
i do the same thing i don't read
articles i'll see a [__] headline
i'll be like oh [__] they're guilty yeah
[__] them or there's no context or who
knows how the [__] does the washington
post report on a podcast from 2018 right
and see the accuracy they're using here
or are they just like this guy's getting
fired for being racist
clicks
clicks clicks it's crazy huh yeah they
don't get no one cares it's all done the
caring is done
the the problem is though is when they
write those articles
after what i've said that doesn't count
when they write an article that says a
slur
like this guy used this slur then normal
people who obviously would have never
heard matt and shane's secret podcast
are like holy [__] he said like they're
just
in the new york times it's like here's
the word that that guy said that's bad
right that would have never reached
these people ever
you know what percentage did your
viewership go up after the article
it probably doubled
yeah since the the months after after
snl our listenership probably quadrupled
yeah for sure because then people heard
about it and watched it so it's helped
the product this is actually funny yeah
it's helped the podcast tremendously
wow yeah yeah i don't
i don't love talking about canceled
culture yeah kind of i guess sorry no no
no don't be sorry i'm kind of i mean i
did it i did it to myself
i'm sorry about that i'm kind of the
gamer culture guy now so i don't know if
you are it's also just a fascinating
topic right now i know it's just it gets
like when people feel like it'll start
to just suddenly that's who you'll
always be then i don't think so i don't
think so either i'm confident i'm not
yeah i'm confident i'm good enough at
stand up that i'm not going to be
that if you guys know that about
yourself then you it's gonna you're
gonna be fine yeah i'm i am fine i'm not
i'm not worried about that
uh i never really was i never was like
this is gonna it'll always be part of my
story that's how i was introduced into
the comedy world yeah but
was there any asian comedians that were
supportive
yeah
for sure that's cool for sure definitely
behind
right closed doors in fact everybody was
supportive behind the scenes right and
that's to my face too so i'm sure there
was a lot of them that weren't very
supportive that weren't just gonna walk
up to me like i've had problems with
people and i'm not gonna walk up to them
be like you know you're a piece of [__]
right so of course nobody's saying it
everything's kind of yeah uh but yeah
there were a lot of people for sure
that's cool man yeah i mean they i think
there were a lot of people that had
conversations with people that knew me
that actually knew me that were like oh
okay
you know like if you see a headline
you're like oh [__] this guy said what
and then you look it up or you call his
friend and you're like is he like a
racist dude and they're like no not at
all he was [__] around yeah it
changes things you're just like oh all
right yeah because i read an article
that said he was racist well it's weird
because it makes it scary to talk about
anything sometimes because you're like
and it's also as podcasters it's like
they could go back through anything and
take out three or four words from so
many things for sure
absolutely
but
not many dudes are getting
i don't know snl seems like one of the
few jobs yeah that they would do that
for like they're not going to go back
and cancel guys
just willy-nilly they're not just gonna
like it's gotta be a big
you know if you're starring in a movie
then people might be like all right
let's take a look at him let's go listen
to a couple apps yeah see his episodes
yeah riley mao you're an asian guy this
is the guy that did it to you how do you
feel
i feel great
do you remember what happened
i do
do you
i do oh nice well not nice but i'm
saying i'm surprised you know about it
because sometimes when people don't know
about it
particularly when they're asian yeah i
gotta be like
well here's what i said
like i'll get done with a show and
there'll be asian there's obviously
there's asian people that like comedy
right they come to shows and they're
like you were our favorite tonight
what's your name
mark norman
you know i mean you don't want to get
hit with the [__] google in front of
you
like they're like
what's your instagram i'll look it up
it's like shane gillis
that was that was the wildest part was
taking the train because i was poor when
i got canceled yeah so like
that's the only way i'd travel and like
people would be on the train like
reading the news and for three days i
was the
i was the new so people would literally
be like
like on the subway like looking at me
sitting there like did you try to look
nicer when you were the news do you
notice at all honestly
you definitely act nicer to everyone
around you when you're in trouble like
that oh for sure you want everyone to
think like he's a nice guy yeah it's
[__] up but you definitely become
a lot now maybe it's because you're not
as stressed about minor things where you
would have an ego with somebody about
like
you just bump me or some [__] like
that right when you're getting canceled
you're like
i love you we love each other right like
it's like you want everyone to like you
because you're getting
destroyed
publicly
maybe i wonder if that's why some
comedians always want everybody they
always i wonder if there's some
correlation in there why a lot of
comedians that's why you want everybody
to like you because you feel like from
the jump or something you've feel like a
bad guy you feel bad yes
maybe i think a lot of comedians feel
bad i feel bad yeah i feel bad most of
the time yeah
uh
but yeah when you when you're getting in
trouble
you're nice to everybody it's very funny
yeah that's cool yeah it's funny knowing
that like
harvey weinstein was probably nice as
hell towards the end
it was probably when the [__] hit the
fan he's probably buying everybody like
harry and dave
i [__] up i know i [__] up
but yeah yeah the whole having to
explain people what happened is a tough
one
yeah yeah
do you feel some type of way over there
riley mao
oh sometimes
no do you have any do you feel anything
about what shane did
oh um
no not really okay yeah i
you guys are good
i appreciate that i appreciate that of
course
i didn't mean anything i apologize
thanks theo that's a good one look at
this oh alley-oop for me is that what
that was what the [__] did you think
that was gonna be how did you think that
was gonna go
here's the guy who did it there's that
son of a [__] who did it how do you
feel about it
here's this opportunity i can't even see
him yeah well i can and it's not
comfortable
my bad man that was funny
oh jesus christ dude yeah bringing me
army like we've actually brought
in one of your victims
it's like that [__] like where you gonna
sit with the murderer's
family or whatever
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one